thank you
uh
oh there you go
yes
i um
uh i want to ask how do you memorize
scripture
i was hoping someone surprised me and
not asked me that but i
it takes hard work my handsome brother
hard work
and i'm not joking hard work um
i was invited to go to house for food
dr judas palace
and uh
i was on the outside reading bible
verses while waiting for the food
to be picked or cooked or
gathered like manna
and i was just going through some
passages
i took the food to my place
and i was going through some passages
when i finished eating
i put on some music there's some there's
some bible passages i recite to pieces
of music i put that on and i started
reciting i started reciting reciting
reciting so when i need it it will come
to me like that
ella white writes in uh my character in
personality volume 2 page 601 paragraph
that which at first seems difficult
by constant repetition grows easy
and right thoughts and actions become
habitual
the same way sin becomes habitual
right thoughts and actions can become
habitual but no one becomes a demon
overnight
no one becomes a saint overnight it
takes practice in demon
whatever or practice in righteous
behavior and so what i recommend to you
is
constant constant practice you may also
write verses on three by four take them
with you and say them i just say them
look away look look look away
that's how i do it but i do it
all
day
virtually
when i'm brushing my teeth i say a
chapter
when i'm showering
i recite a chapter or a passage you see
you learn to do several things at the
same time here i am taking a shower
that's let's say five minutes
what else can i do with those five
minutes
i can recite some bible verses
i'm driving somewhere let's say driving
from amity to a little rock how long is
that two hours
what else can you do but just look at
the road are you following me or chat
with someone next to you you recite
bible verses
if you only know one john 11 35 jesus
swept you say it and you think about it
you think what is the message in this
verse for me and so what i recommend but
ask god to give you see when you desire
something no one can stop you
when the the builders of the tower of
babel the bible says and the lord came
down to see the city and the tower which
the children of men build it genesis 11
verse 5 and the lord said behold the
people is one
and have all one language and this they
begin to do and now
nothing will be restrained from them
which they have imagined to do they were
so determined to build that tower god
said the only power in the universe that
can stop them that's me
he says nothing will be restrained from
them
yes
i'm sure you've heard of young people
who jump out the window to go see their
boyfriend or girlfriend they fight with
their parents nothing will restrain them
are you following me from seeing that
little boy little girl they love well
apply that god's word
but also understand the value
this is your chief weapon against
temptation
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one the scriptures are the great agency
in the transformation of character
jesus prayed sanctify them through thy
truth this is the truth what did jesus
tell the disciples in john 15 3 now you
clean through the word you understand
the word in your head not only memorized
like a poem but
functioning as a principle in your life
that is the victory that is the power
that intimidates satan and since you're
all young psalm 119 verse 9 wherewithal
shall a young man cleanse his ways a
young woman by taking heed there too
according to that we do not understand
the power of god's word is released
through the obedience of faith
the same power that said let there be
light on the light came is right in your
hand
elon might write the same creative
energy that called the worlds into
existence is in the word of god this
word imparts power it begets life every
command is a promise accepted by the
will received into the soul it brings
with the life of the infinite one it
transforms the nature and recreates the
soul in the image of god page 126
paragraph 4 of education this is your
power to conquer satan this is your
defense against the overpowering
deception that is already coming on this
earth this is your victory studied and
obeyed christ object lessons page 100
paragraph 1 the last statement says if
studied and obeyed they must go together
the word of god works in the heart
subduing every unholy attribute
you name the unholy attribute you're
wrestling with studied and obeyed
what does the devil do he doesn't get
you to rob banks he just take you away
from the word this all
take them from the word let them go to
church
let them go where canvassing
let them have no time for the word
that's all now he'd be delighted if you
blew up buildings or whatever but the
fundamental thing is get them from the
word and you have them
they'll be decent vegetarians on the way
to hell because they had no time for the
word of god
this
and our seventh-day adventist this plus
the precious council of ellen white
sometimes i pray i thank god
for ellen white's ministry
i thank god for the ministry of the
pioneers and otherwise said read what
they wrote because they study the word
in the way we do not understand my young
friends
this by the way
this will improve your academic
performance christ object lessons page
125 paragraph three
if
the follower of christ
will believe his word
and practice it
there is no science in the natural world
he will not be able to grasp and
appreciate what does that mean grass
means understand appreciate me is
connected with the great creator if the
follower of christ
will believe his word and true belief
requires action and practice it there is
no science in the natural world
he will not be able to grasp and
appreciate
want to do better
here's your secret because it
strengthens the mind
and it makes comprehension much easier
i recommend
the word of god
as your strength
your light what should i do thy word is
a lamp unto my feet and a light unto my
path what direction should i take psalm
25 4 show me thy ways of lord teach me
thy past this is you see
sorry for taking so long this question
tell me if this makes sense
how was the heavens made
by the word how is the earth made
then
can you not see if you've been placed in
a universe
made by the word
there is no other life to live to be
consistent with god's universe than to
live by the word
and so jesus says man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word
the same word that created the universe
the same word that sustains the universe
ii peter 3 7 is the word by which you
and i should live
this is life
all right
you